[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live laura cognito
here iron lord podcast lords of
gaming.net and who is this foreign lady
that we have in the realm of pax east
today hi i'm maddie gray i'm the senior
community manager here at base yourself
games awesome awesome so we got lord
addict going gameplay what is this game
that we're playing right now what is
this that we're talking about so what
we're playing right now is industries of
titan
it is a cyberpunk industrial city
builder sims strategy game
is what we call it a lot going on
there's a lot going on okay um so we
kind of have y'all starting midway
through this game right now um and since
you
haven't played this before
we're just kind of like throwing you in
there there might be a lot of stuff so
if there's any questions at any point
i've played a lot of these type of games
okay so you you know the gist um usually
when the game starts you have just this
one building the headquarters and you
build everything out from there
what makes titan special is that you can
go into certain buildings so if you
click on like the headquarters for
example
you can enter it
and you have a whole other layer here oh
so this is another there's an interior
layer
oh wow that's cool that's cool yeah so
that's what uh really makes titan unique
in that you can build it's like so micro
but also very happy
so as far as the micro management
interior what would be some of the
things that you would do as a player to
i guess maximize you know as far as the
the end game of what your whole world
goes to the game how does that how does
interior building help you in the flow
of the game
so interior building is generally more
uh you get more from it so you can
choose whether you want to build things
quicker with like larger buildings or
you can get like more packed into a
single one
and usually it's a really good way to
get your corporation off the ground
before you start building really
outwards and make a sprawling city
across tight yeah so out of curiosity i
assume that
there's micro managing
from the buildings itself because you
have generators so you have to go into
these buildings and get whatever
resources they need to continue being
active
okay
cool cool and then again you know we're
talking about the cyberpunk aesthetic
corporation kind of vibe you know what's
the general is there like a narrative
based theme with the game is there a
storyline a progression yeah so we're
actually going to be coming out with a
campaign mode pretty soon
but the general story behind titan is
that oh well it takes place first of all
on saturn's moon titan that's where the
name goes
it's kind of like a pun on titan of
industries but it's industries of titans
because
our boss just really likes fun
industry
that's literally why this game was born
ah that's why they didn't think okay we
got it now we got it though yeah um so
you're
this new founder on this moon
backed by this mysterious council who
are just these uh rich benefactors who
are like okay you start this this uh
corporation and you become successful so
that i get a return on my investment um
and they're ruthless so you in turn have
to play this ruthless
founder who kind of exploits both the
planet as well as your citizens and
employees could you give me a quick
example of how
we as a player could exploit the
citizens in that way
to our benefactors so there's this thing
called uh conversion
so
there's the little capsules the devices
inside your factories or you can build
actual buildings for it okay but you
literally take a citizen
you convert them into an employee
and what it does is it like
strips them of their need to eat sleep
and they just become these automatons
basically that just work non-stop and do
what they're told
um you still have to pay them okay
there's some ethics with this
it's pretty much like
you're forcing them to be more
aggressive at their job
yeah pretty much
um and it's technically a voluntary
process
but you know
it's that's how it goes
the objective is to you know
complete these resources replay these
investors i noticed that there's rebel
camps here there are
what kind of call that's in this guy so
if you go into your
shipyard here actually
you can enter it
and i believe we have a ship prepared
for you here okay yeah so you might want
to display it it looks like there's
still some devices that need to be built
so you'll see your employees kind of
come in here build those and then you
can launch it
uh so then there's kind of like ftl
style combat if you put it to you oh
yeah yeah so uh you can like look at the
it goes like half screen and you kind of
choose
which little parts of the ship that you
want to fight and you also have turrets
so you can if they come invade to you
you can blast them out of the sky that
way
and i i noticed when i was in the
headquarters there was a combat one that
wasn't available in me that's if someone
evades you fight there right that uh is
something that we're still working on
and hasn't become available yet so when
let's say that someone ends up coming in
and trying to invade you can like can
you like send your [ __ ] to countless
ship to camera yes
that's the idea and then you can also
explore the fog of war find their camps
destroy their camps although they'll
also have turrets so it can be difficult
now
with the ships are like
do you have to like move supplies around
with them or they just specifically for
combat they're specifically for combat
we have kind of because we're in early
access right now right right um and we
have been for a long time and we've
toyed around with so many different
ideas um at some point we need to kind
of like figure like what's our actual
1.0 because this game can be anything
and everything like there's so many cool
things so many um but yeah it's
something that we've talked about so i
don't want to say never but still still
want to take it yes yeah one thing
that's cool is like i said you should
have been a city builder type of games
very cool very in-depth now is this
going to have maybe for the
casual player who may not be used to
these type of games is there going to be
some form of a tutorial to try to get
them up to speed with the gameplay
mechanics absolutely yeah i actually
consider myself a pretty casual player
in terms of forex strategy games um and
i find this game very fun um i'm also i
mean i'm kind of biased but
i think it's true
as like a disclaimer
but like
i see here that there's a time frame
oh yeah so are these like where the
resources are coming from that you have
to wait for them to get there no so
well i guess this is a type of resource
this is how you get immigrants and like
um i guess new citizens to your city
corporation
um so you literally like buy
uh people in this game got it um yeah we
have a whole bunch of different advisors
so going back to your question is there
a tutorial yes there's actually a really
robust tutorial that's like fully vo'd
lots of characterization
um
yeah so i i've lost so many hours to
this game i'm just like i should
probably catch up and see what's going
on i haven't played this game in a while
um
five hours gone i'm like wait i had to
do other work today so is that what you
wanted to get going uh yeah so this is
this is if there was an enemy um that's
what you would see so uh right now
there's no enemies to fight
um but there will be soon
so
uh the rebel threat meter works on like
how well you're doing as a corporation
so it doesn't go on like a time base
it's like how much you're building and
how much value you have as a so the more
value that you have the
less the rebels like you and they'll be
like i want to get rid of that person
gotcha so i assume you can
upgrade these turrets is there different
versions of these cards or is it really
just
just let's go yeah yeah so this one's
already level three one i think there
might be one more to the north that's a
little yeah that's a level one or two
yes level two so so as you progression
and assuming the difficulty ramps up
what are some of the other threats or
things that the player must be cognizant
of as you go on on a hardcore partner
so actually um our next update so we do
monthly updates for this game uh we're
on update like 22 right now our next
one's going to be update 23 and it's
going to be introducing rival
corporations
so that was my thing i was trying to see
like okay
yeah so right now the main thread has
always just been the rebels yes and uh
they're kind of just like a pest um
you're like
i need to get rid of you the rival
corporations are also backed by the
council so you can't just stomp them out
like that right
so
uh if you actually click on the very
right
uh next to the if you up at the top to
the right
nope a little bit left that one there we
go okay you have some corporate goals
yes so this is how you kind of achieve
victory in this game you can choose
which cut which area you want to master
so you can be martial mastery political
powerhouse or uh economic expertise
let's rebel around keita
destroy three bits
and then local leader okay okay
so
when you add the i believe
like the
yeah the rival corporation yeah the
rival corporations is that gonna be that
like there's gonna be other corporations
that are trying to fit themselves up
against you
like some espionage kind of stuff going
yeah they'll actually be on the map so
right now this map is 64 by 64. we're
increasing it to 72 by 72 which is like
over a thousand more squares actually um
and there'll be other
sometimes more than one other uh rival
corporation on the map
and you can actually see there's another
tab for them you can see what their
goals are so you can strategically
sabotage the specific areas that they're
trying to do it's kind of a unique way
it's like civilization yeah you
[Music]
yeah when the rebel corporations are
kind of like
that when they come in
are they gonna be in your city space or
are you gonna be in a different city
space and kind of like taking over your
cities a different city space and kind
of like you're vying with them for
territory and money turn towards yes
like they have their own territory and
you have to kind of
take them yeah remove them politely
and i know this is going to be a way out
of their questions
right something like a rivals kind of
makes me think that maybe down the line
like some kind of multiplayer might be
all
this is actually something we get asked
about a lot a lot of people really want
multiplayer um and it's something we
would love to do but we are just
focusing right now on the first player
experience
and going from there you know
so it's just something that's you know
not on the table now but it's not out of
the play it's not out of the question
but not on the table now exactly good
looks absolutely fantastic and oh sorry
about please i was gonna say uh you
actually can go into your science labs
too and there's a whole tech web
um
where you can make or research some
technologies and this is really cool
it's really cool it's randomly generated
each game
right yeah
makes you think more yeah yeah the
really important ones are weighted
towards the beginning because we found
that players were like well there was
one thing that we really really wanted
but it was like way out to the far side
of our web so we're like okay we'll make
that closer but it is randomly generated
we want to encourage people to try new
strategies according to like what's
available with them otherwise uh people
kind of get stuck in one way of playing
the game so we want to encourage them to
get out of their comfort zone that's
really cool that's really cool now the
upper right hand corner i'm saying the
day night cycle the sleep cycle like
this now again this is like slowing time
progression of the game
all right okay cool and um again it's
coming from a standpoint of
what type like can you miss goals are
certain things time gated as far as
goals and activities
yeah yeah we don't want to overwhelm
players when they first start so if you
go into the corporate goals again the
one on the right yeah you can see if you
go down to economic expertise
um you can unlock it now
and the price gets lower every time so
it will unlock automatically at a
certain point but if you want access to
them earlier you can unlock them that's
really cool with money yeah and i like
what i don't think i like is very
specific with the directives and
objectives and also seeing what the
rival corporations could do again really
what a person like me who loves these
games but sometimes it can be
intimidating
having that structure really helpful
yeah so i like that okay now you got to
hold my hand with it i'm totally there
with you yeah but i have to have a
general idea of what i'm doing and
that's what i feel is missing from a lot
of these type of games and to me this is
very appealing as well as the aesthetic
and how cool it looks i think the
interesting thing is just like how you
guys i've never seen someone want you to
like micromanage buildings too yeah so
it's a unique thing where i'm assuming
like when the rifles come out like since
you got the micromax they'll be able to
sabotage you yeah exactly so
there if you might want to pause because
our rebels are about to attack
watch them
so if you notice in your corporate goals
there are
some locks and some stars
um and so that means if if a star has a
lock on it that means it's an
irrevocable goal once you achieve it you
achieve it but everything else you can
attain that goal but if you go back
below it you lose that star and the same
goes for your rivals so you can see what
they have okay and you're like oh they
have um 18 council obelisks let me
destroy a couple and get rid of that
goal for them um
so that they don't have that goal
anymore and you're closer to the victory
than they are that's cool so a lot of
push pull yeah that is really kind of
like the like civilization where
someone's trying to go for a nuke or
something like that you're preventing
those steps before that yeah yeah very
cool yeah we're actually planning an
update to the corporate goals too so
this isn't going to be the final thing
it's kind of curious when this goes yeah
yeah he won't see that okay
here we go he's for the violence of the
attacking part
oh it's fully voiced
there we go so you might want to go and
get your ship
oh wow
it's going down
where'd your ship go
they are attacking
select their ship yeah i think he
already launched the ship yeah okay
sorry it's in the city somewhere
uh there he is right above your shipyard
[Music]
uh you gotta right click yeah
so you're also paused right now oh yeah
right it's going to pause let's get to
it
we gotta get these rebels out of here
here we go
yeah they they turn that building up
they're tearing up headquarters
so once they're engaged you can enter
the ship
and that's when you'll get to this
combat so
what you can do is you can just do it
real time but what a lot of people like
to do is they like to pause
get their put their lasers here and then
you can choose on the enemy where to go
and you can rotate it with ours
if there's certain parts of the ship
that's more deadly than others
it's like a puzzle so there are certain
things where you have to like look at
this and be like okay they only have
like two life supports if i get rid of
their life supports all those employees
are going to suffocate um or like oh i'm
taking so much damage i need to get rid
of one of the drinks
it's so calculated
yes uh these this is like a level
one ship i believe this is also level
one they go up to level three and
they're pretty massive
nice yeah it's actually really funny
because ships can actually operate
without employees if you only have
engines in them and the more engines you
put in a ship the faster they'll go so
some people just make these super super
fast scout ships that just go around and
you can get them to do little donuts
so much strategy here that's so fun
that's less about the strategy and more
about the the cool factor in that one
but you can't do much with a ship that
has no guns yeah you kind of need people
in it yeah i won that they okay
yeah so you might want to pause
um so one of the a recent update
recently added fire which is a big
threat to your corporation
um and fire can spread yeah so
how do we stop this what you can do is
you can select your headquarters
which is this one here
um and i recommend you burrow actually
to get rid of all those fires and then
you can play again
so this is also something that you can
do preemptively when a rebel attacks you
if you can burrow all your buildings so
they can't attack the building
it's almost like a defense mechanism
okay we're gonna protect this now
headquarters can be borrowed as well no
no no the headquarters cannot be brought
is there a way that they can counter
that you should also hit repair
is there a way that they can counter the
railway no uh but the burrowing only
lasts for a short amount of time and it
also costs a lot of credits
so if they send a significant amount of
forces it's not going to matter
[Music]
interesting defensive mechanic very cool
we heard it here first now again early
access early access right now for people
who want to know about english
entitlement where can they go besides
that is there a discord is anything else
yeah we have a we have a discord we're
at discord.com brace yourself games we
have a website race yourself games.com
nice um it's also available right now on
the epic game store and steam
so hopefully we'll get to 1.0 soon we
don't have a set date yet but we can
hopefully say something soon very cool a
lot of potential cyberpunk corporate
themes
interior exterior loving the vibe rebel
camps attic how are you feeling about
that
i've always enjoyed these type of uh
resource abilities
you know this is more unique in terms of
i would say
i've never played a type of game
gameplay
but i've never seen one take so many
from all of them yeah very good i'm
biased i love the psycho cybernetic
cyberpunk aesthetic i'm in i'm in
incorporate on titan let's go in the
street
a pleasure thank you so much lady mata
for showing us this game make sure you
guys check it out industry of titan the
lords are keeping an eye on the sun
[Music]
you